evacuating residents from her son is a
deadly business
votes move swiftly through
floods-stricken areas not only ferrying
people to dry land
but to escape the ongoing Russian
bombardment oh mother's this elderly man
was rescued by volunteers from his
submerged home only to be filmed moments
later with a head wound caused by flying
shrapnel a rescue worker was asked what
it was like operating under these
conditions
before indicating he needed to get going
because of incoming fire dear friends we
just Ukraine's Chief Rabbi Moshe Ruben
Osman was helping emergency crews bring
residents to safety when more shelling
landed nearby to bring people over here
from all the river and the Russian